so I'm Xander um and I'm excited to be
here today uh maybe introduce some of
you to realtime data and streaming data
or um maybe brought in some of your
knowledge on the topic uh so today
realtime data is all around us uh you
know interacting on social media whether
it be messages or interactions or the
financial
markets uh or in manufacturing where
autonomous robots do a lot of the
manufacturing today creating data in
real time
or even our vehicles where knowingly or
unknowingly um they collect some 25
gigabytes of data per hour which is uh
really quite scary and also shocking uh
or in our devices we carry that are
knowingly or unknowingly tracking us in
our day day-to-day lives so the data is
all around us and companies today are
leading companies today are kind of
leveraging streaming data um as an
advantage and so I think it's really
relevant uh for practitioners and
developers and technologists in these in
Piata Global talks to kind of learn
about how we can stay relevant and Excel
by knowing how to work with um realtime
data so before we go any further a
little further introduction to myself so
my name is Xander I'm working on bite
wax um bwax is a state fullstream
processor it's open source and it's
python native we'll talk more about that
later
um as a solution to real-time data
outside of work I'm a proud human and
dog dad that's my daughter z uh if
you're thinking about doing a startup or
having a child don't do both at the same
time it makes things a little harder uh
outside of work I like to get outside um
this is in New Hampshire on uh
tuckerman's Ravine which uh we locked
out on a windless day if you haven't
been there it's one of the windiest
places in the world so we got really
lucky uh when I'm not uh in the bite wax
slack Channel you can also find me in
Santa Cruz in person if you're here send
me a LinkedIn message and happy to grab
a coffee okay so that's me um we got
that out of the way so what are we doing
today uh we're going to talk about
real-time data we're going to talk about
what streaming data is uh then we're
going to do give you an introduction to
bite wax uh as a solution to working
with streaming data and then do a little
working example uh with code that you
can follow along along and I'll share
afterward uh so first off very high
level maybe a little bit fuzzy uh but
what is the definition of real time so
real time uh could be defined as
anything that a human uh perceives to
have happened in real time which is like
kind of a crappy definition so what it
translates into is things that are in
the subc realm um and depending on your
application that of of whatever you're
doing it could mean closer to zero or
closer to like happing instantaneously
or
not um what does that mean in the scope
of data so real time in the world of
data real time means that the data is
available for use as soon as is as it is
generated that the data is processed
immediately and that the data is made
available to the consumer or whoever is
the end user or end consumer of that
data
postprocessing immediately as well so
all of this process needs to happen in a
real time and low latency
manner so that's great we know what
realtime data is so what is streaming
data so streaming data is actually the
technology or capability to enable real
time but we'll get into that a little
bit more um uh what I like to do in
describing what streaming data is is
kind of use it as a comparison with
batch so so first thing we can look at
is the data itself so a stream of data
is a continuously generated and
unbounded set of data um unbounded is
kind of the keyword there um we don't
know what the end of the data looks like
in some cases you don't even know when
it's going to arrive uh a batch of data
in contrast is a defined bounded um set
of data and due to the nature of the
differences in these and the data um we
use different processing techniques and
paradigms and that led to stream
processing and batch processing
paradigms stream processing um is
effectively uh processing each data as
it arrives sort of one at a time um is
like a loose definition we can use and
whereas batch processing is where you
have that entire set of data and you're
doing the processing over the whole
batch uh one of the nuan is here is that
both of these uh techniques could in
fact um provide a solution that is real
time depending on your application if
you squish your batches smaller and
smaller and
smaller um you could get to A A solution
that happens in what is perceived to be
real time but it's not always the
latency that you require and there's
some other nuances there but at this
point you might be wondering okay if if
microb batching can solve the problem
why do I even need stream processing so
we're going to take a little like Sid
trck here um oh we got to reconnect this
thing I like to use um generators python
generators as a a little tool for kind
of describing um streaming data it works
for me it's not a perfect uh way to do
it but it's a nice a nice little example
so um in Python we have this idea of
generators where uh you know it's an
iterable type of object and every time
you request the next uh thing it will
provide you with what's available um and
so we can kind of showcase this by
making a little um generator here called
My Stream and it's basically going to
yield out a random indure um between
zero and 10 uh and we'll have this sort
of fake stream of data you can imagine
this could be a uh stream of sensor data
and it's just sort of like the
temperature or or something like that if
you want a more concrete um way to tie
that
down okay so in uh streaming data you
have this idea of the actual stream of
data so in our case that's the generator
that might be a um set of sensors iot
sensors Telemetry data whatever
generating uh these values and then it's
uh available as a stream and so those
are called the producers and then you
have on the other side the the consumers
and those are those that are consuming
the data Downstream um we can kind of
stub this as a uh a handle on our
generator and so in practice when we
think about streaming data we think of
the data as being pushed towards the
consumer but in reality it ends up
mostly being that the consumer is asking
uh
Downstream uh or sorry is asking what's
available from the system that's sort of
holding what was produced by
um the producer and so we can simulate
this by saying okay what's next in the
Stream and next in the Stream in this
case it's it's kind of generating that
so it's faked but you could understand
that it's asking basically the consumer
saying hey what's next what's next give
me the next data give me the next
data uh now the next step would be to
process that data um for whatever reason
this is like a gener generally
applicable thing the same way you
process batches of data there can be so
many reasons reasons why you would
process the stream of
data um and it can be very
straightforward you
may just want to take that stream of
data and uh maybe enrich it or filter
out something maybe you want to mask an
email or maybe you just want to divide
the number by two uh which is what we've
simulated here so we can take our um
generator and which is our stream and
we're just going to kind of iterate it
it iterate over it and modify the items
wanted time um that can only get you so
far so at some point in your journey of
using streaming data you're going to run
into the idea that you want to have an
idea uh or sorry you want to have a a
context of what has already happened
before you get that next data uh data
and so that might be that you um you're
looking to have a window over time and
you can say hey I actually want the
average of know how how many or average
of the values over a window of time or
maybe you just want to collect a certain
number of items and then um reduce them
so you get these sort of uh slightly
more difficult things to do and we've
we've wrote a little um way to Showcase
a very very simple example where we're
just basically uh maintaining two values
and then getting the mean of those
values
um and there you can see that so we're
kind of playing around with like a
stream of data and the different things
you can do with it uh and you might at
this point in time um be thinking to
yourself okay that's super easy why do I
even need a stream processor um why
can't I just you know do what we were
doing right there and kind of loop over
these generators and it gets complicated
rather
quickly uh so what would happen if we
had many different sensors
providing those values and so we had
many different keys and when whenever we
did our computations we actually had to
make sure that the right data was added
up or right data was accumulated for the
right key and then what if we needed to
do a Time based window so what if our
values were provided with event time or
they were provided or they weren't
provided with event time and we had to
figure out system time or or how to
parse that event time and how to create
a Time based window and all the edge
cases associated with that but if it's a
rolling window or a tumbling window or
all the different types of Windows or
you might say to yourself hey I multiple
streams of data how do I put them all
together in the right way and how do I
reason about that and then maybe you
have a situation where you have a
machine uh that crashed or your system
crashed and you need to figure out where
you were in the Stream So that you can
start processing again and what happened
to all those uh averages that you were
or or the accumulating values that you
had going on for those different keys
and then finally where it gets
complicated and we get into the realm of
distributed processing is what do you
need to do when things need to scale up
how do we make sure that the right data
goes to the right node or process or our
calculations are
correct um so it's not the processing of
one item at a time that makes streaming
data hard it's when we put all of those
things together and so that's why stream
processors exist and that's why Bix
exists Bix uh is exists to provide a
pythonic way to process streams of data
without having to worry about the
complexity and the details that you
probably started to imagine when I was
listing them out there so stream
processors give us um uh easy to use um
semantics to connect to streaming data
sources and then process that data as
Windows or with joins or to filter and
enrich it and then also on how to scale
our ability to have uh to process more
data so to increase the
throughput so at this point in time um I
want to introduce uh B wax I mean I
already kind of have through through
that but
uh um I'll just kind of get more
concrete here so if you're not familiar
with bwax it's an extremely extensible
data processing framework at a high
level it was designed to be streaming
first um with a python uh Native
interface so that you can take advantage
of the whole python ecosystem it uses a
rust engine it's based on top of an
open- Source uh rust uh processing
engine called timely data
flow that allows you to do all those
stateful streaming um stream processing
uh capabilities that you want window
aggregations Etc uh and then it's uh
easy to scale uh in a cloud native
capacity so you can run it on top of
kubernetes um and there's no like vendor
lock in there um and then it's also has
all the niceties around that you don't
want to think about like hey my node
crashed I need to recover um those sort
of things uh one of the additional nice
pieces that that I think differentiates
byak is that it can run literally almost
anywhere there are people running it
today on kubernetes or on single nodes
or on Raspberry pies or in like Edge
Computers on ships and in um aircraft so
that's I mean it was cool for me to see
that uh become
real um okay so on with how we're going
to use bwax as a solution to some of
these um difficult streaming problems or
just to make life working with streaming
data easier and to do that I think in
The Proposal it actually said I was
going to do some Hacker News analysis
thing I do have something for that I can
share later but uh what we're going to
do right now is uh analyzing Wikimedia
event streams because it's readily
available it's a stream um and it's it's
easy to do some fairly interesting stuff
with it uh so if you're not familiar
with Wikipedia's event stream I'll just
quickly show you what it is so they have
different parts of the API they want of
those is like the recent changes so
these are people editing all the
different Wikipedia
assets um clear V and so you can see
these fill up pretty good um it's not
like anything crazy but uh yeah there's
enough uh real- time data here for us to
do something
interesting um so we're going to make us
a DAT uh we're going to make a streaming
uh workload to understand what's
happening on the Wikipedia recent events
change log so this is um what we call
with bwx we call this a data flow a nice
way to describe any data processing
whether it be batch or uh streaming is
through a graph um you've probably heard
DS before directed A graphs so it's a
nice way to visualize and understand
where you have a node for sort of each
um capability or transformation that
you're doing so so in this case we have
a input node um where we're actually
streaming those um HTTP stream events
and then we'll have a uh processing node
where we do some derc serialization and
then we're going to for reformat the
data so that we can use it in a window
then we're going to accumulate our data
in a window and then we can uh
understand it uh we kind of simplified
this example where we're just going to
print it out in our from our output node
which is just a standard output but you
would in a production system you would
move your data somewhere else where it
can be retrieved by um some other part
of the application uh or or even just
stored for for later
usage all right so now we're going to
jump into writing some code and then we
can or looking at some code I guess and
then we can uh uh run this
workflow uh I need unfortunate thing
about sharing your whole screen is I
can't actually see if they questions or
if I'm running out of time but I think
I'm still good here so um like I
mentioned um stream processors provide
semantics to describe how to connect the
data sources um do some processing and
then how to write out to different syncs
so in biox there's an API for writing
input and there's also built-in in input
connectors um so you can connect to
kafco websockets uh htb streams you can
even connect to do non streaming things
if you wanted to use it in a batch
manner but for this use case we're going
to connect to an SSE um stream which is
the Wikipedia stream and we're going to
write a custom connector to do that um
we're going to look at the code to write
a custom connector to do that so should
all see my vs code over here um biox is
just biox data flows for writing biox
data flows for stream processing is just
like writing regular python code which
is of nice um you do have to know some
of the like nuances of the API when you
get into doing more advanced things like
using the custom input and output
connectors um the reason being is that
uh the B wax um processing engine is is
meant to allow you to do distributed
processing and so you you need to have
at least or you need to at least provide
the ability for users to um write input
connectors that uh allow you to process
partitions of data so that you can
actually speed up your throughput you
can imagine in some uh systems you have
the data is already partitioned so in
Kafka for example the data is
partitioned by keys or or something like
that um and uh so when you ride a
connector to achieve the highest
throughput you want to be able to have a
separate worker for each one of those um
partitions so that you can maximize um
how much data you're processing okay so
that's like a total Divergence but so
we've written a Wikipedia
um uh input connector here uh what will
happen in bite wax is we're going to
we're going to um create a data flow
object and then we're going to use the
input um operator uh which is a class
method of the data flow and um we're
going to assign it this Wiki source that
we created up here so behind the scenes
what biox does is going to say okay what
are the parts of this source so what are
the partitions in this case there's just
one because it's HTTP event stream we
can't have multiple partitions there and
then it's going to say okay cool now I
want you to build the partition so each
worker will build its partition we only
have one in this case but it's going to
build that partition which which in turn
returns this Wiki partition and the wiki
partition is the actual code that
describes how we're going to iterate
through so if you remember the
generator this is kind of like working
like a generator so this partition thing
is going to have a um it's going to have
some um uh Handler or handle sorry into
the uh the stream and then it's going to
have this functionality that says get me
the next batch of data whe whether
that's one or whether that's
um a thousand you can actually um tune
that in this case we're using an async
library with in this so B Bix is
synchronous many libraries in Python are
asynchronous so this is a way to deal
with the asynchronous library so we're
basically using a workaround to kind of
batch up the asynchronous um uh
generator up here and the generator
itself is where we actually attach to
Wikipedia's recent change okay so that's
like the hardest part this is like it's
like starting on Advanced that's like
the hardest part about Bix is making
your own custom input if we were just
using Kafka all we would do would have
we would just write one line down here
that just said like Kafka source and
then my topic name and that was that
would be all we need to
do all right so next up um I have to
apologize I can't see the chat or any of
the questions so I will work on those at
the end hopefully I leave enough time um
because I I I can't answer them as we go
so the next part we want to do here is
we want to take this data from Wikimedia
oftentimes we're going to have to
deserialize or parse that and then we're
going to prep that data to be used uh in
the next steps and when I say prep that
data um it was what I mentioned before
that we need to get it in the right
format for our window where we um have
the user key as the first part of our um
T but I'll talk about that in a second
so we're going to use uh simple
operators and you'll see them in the
data flow we go back to the code so map
is like a onetoone transformation the
way this works in biox is
you uh use the map operator and you pass
it a um function and basically for every
piece of data coming through you're
going to run that function so every time
we get a new uh event from Wiki stream
uh W sorry the Wikimedia will use Json
loads to uh turn it from a Json to a
dictionary and then we're going to key
on user so the reason we're going to key
on user here what we're doing is we're
going to look at how many events a user
does in a Time window um and so in order
to do that we need to be able to group
the um events by the user so that's why
we pull out that user
key uh okay so the next step now that we
have our data format formatted correctly
is the fold window and then we're going
to do our little like calculation and
postprocessing um window operators or
batch operators or join operators they
are uh the kind of more advanced uh
capabilities that are the reason why
stream processors exist U keep things in
order uh to make it easier to reduce
things over time and uh have simple
semantics to describe different types of
streams so this is what
a um window looks like in bite wax so
there are a couple important things we
need to call out um one is that we need
to know how to parse the time so there
is a functionality to uh provide a Time
function and that's passed into the fold
window so in our flow we're adding a new
operator another node in the graph and
that's a fold a fold window operator and
it's given a name and the reason for the
name is has to do with State and State
Recovery um which we're going to skip
for now uh it's giv an event clock conf
or it's giving a clock configuration so
that can either be system or event
time it's given the function that you're
going to use for how to get the event
time and then it tells you this this
little thing here tells you how long to
wait for late arriving data which I said
is arbitrarily at two seconds the next
thing we need to Define is the type of
window so there are a few different
types of Windows one of which is a
tumbling window which is just sort of
like discrete time chunks and what
happens in between
those um next in the tumbling window we
need to tell uh um bite wax what is the
object that we're going to accumulate
things in in this fold window operator
because we're not reducing yet and then
we need to tell bwax what's the actual
functionality we want to use to
accumulate so we're saying hey we want
everything in this window of time to be
in a list and we want to use this
function to build that list and in that
function we're just appending to the
list and we're saying we want the title
and the time
stamp and then the final calculation
which is super simple that we're going
to do in the final formatting and then
we're going to wrap this up so we have
at least a minute or two for qu Q&A is
that um we're going to run another map
with a Lambda function uh in that Lambda
function we're pulling out the length uh
which is just the count of how many
changes they made uh and then the
username so let's run this thing so to
run it this is one other nice thing and
this is part of the reason we designed
bite wax this way is you can just run by
Wax locally in process like you are
writing run like a flask app or
something like that so we using the B
wax run module we're going to run our
data flow uh and run the
flow oops wait maybe I'm not in the
right oh misspelled
sorry um cool so this should start
turning out things after 5 Seconds has
gone by let's make this way
bigger see what's going
on
so the next thing we could do here that
would be fun is we can like look at the
bot I'm going to stop this in a
second so we can go back and we can look
at you know what human is making
modifying 12 Pages it looks like it's a
bot so there's so you can tell when
there are Bots and maybe you could
determine if there were malicious Bots
some way should per form um okay so uh
wrapping this all
up um
that's it uh thank you for listening I'm
going to turn back and look at um things
if you want to go to BX and give us a
star that would be really appreciated
okay uh here we go questions Patrick
asked is it possible to replay the
stream or is the processing stateless uh
this depends on the the where the stream
comes from if the stream itself is
replayable yes so bwax will handle
persisting State um it will handle
tracking progress uh so if you're using
kofka you can recover from the uh the
the right offset and you'll recover with
the right
State um Markus answered let's see if we
can get another
one another
question uh link to GitHub is it an
overall Pi data GitHub I think you all
can see the resources and I'll post that
as well in the
Discord um in the resources tab I don't
know what your exact screen looks like
there's a link to the GitHub repo it is
bwax
bwax um it is not part of uh Pi data no
it is not in the overall Piata GitHub no
it's not in pi dat Hub it's a separate
um company and uh
project um that looks like all the
questions I
[Music]
had cool and I think we're we're over
time here or we're just at time so I
think we're I think we're
good um yeah I think you all will be
going to your next session now thank you
so much for for coming um yeah see yall
later